Greetings to my 3ABN family at home and
welcome to another 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
I'm Ricky Carter and I'll be your host
today. Well, we've got another
hourpacked program with your Bible
questions and we've got the answers
right here in the word of God of which
our panelists will be sharing with us.
And speaking of panelists, let me
introduce you to them right now. To my
right, we have Sister Shelley Quinn.
Welcome, sister. Oh, it's such a joy to
be here. Thank you for sending in your
questions, giving us this opportunity to
really study out the answers. Amen.
Amen. And next to her, I have my
brother, Pastor Daniel Moronei. Welcome,
brother. Thank you so much, Ricky. What
a blessing and a privilege it is to
answer the questions that you send in.
Amen. Amen. And then next to him via
Skype, we have my brother, Pastor James
Rafferty. Welcome, brother. Always good
to be here, Ricky. Thankful for the
opportunity to answer questions and
thankful to be here with uh Shelley and
with Daniel. Amen. Amen. Well, before we
get into the word of God and looking at
these answers, why don't we invite the
Holy Spirit's presence to be with us?
Pastor Mooney, could you pray for us,
please? Yes, it be my privilege. Loving
Father, thank you so much that we have
your word. You have preserved your word,
brought it down to us today. your Holy
Spirit inspired these writers of this
your word. And Lord, we're praying for
your Holy Spirit now to inspire us and
um your inspiration would come through
your word as we share with our viewers
and with each other. Thank you for
hearing our prayer and your presence
with us now and with those that are
watching in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Well, Shel, before I give
you your first question, let me remind
our viewers at home how you can
participate. You can do so one of three
ways. You can send us an email with your
questions to
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. Or you can text us your
questions to
618-2283975. That's
6182283975. And then for those of you
who are on Instagram, you can send us
your questions in that way to
3ABN_official at
3abn_official. All right, Sister
Shelley, here's your first question.
Why does the 7th Day Adventist Church
teach that God is a triune God when
Jesus in John chapter 17 verses 1-3
states that his father is the only true
God. That's from Bill who emailed that
to us. Bill, we never make a doctrine
out of a single scripture. The seventh
day Adventist believed in a triune God
because the Bible clearly reveals a
Godhead, the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit as three distinct persons being
one essence if you will. They a
co-eternal essence. John 17:3 Jesus
said, "This is eternal life that they
may know you, the only true God."
Remember this is the person of Jesus
Christ as the son of man, the son of
God. He is God incarnate. And he says
that they may know you, the only true
God in Jesus Christ whom you have sent.
He's not
denying his own divinity, but in his
humility as the son of man, he is
recognizing the father and exalting him.
He's not excluding himself because Jesus
was still fully divine. He is fully God.
John 1:1 says, "In the beginning was the
word. The word was with God. The word
was God." Verse 14 said, "The word, this
God, became flesh." We see the same in
Philippians uh 2 5-8 where Paul's saying
he was in the form of God. He was God,
but he did not think it's something to
hold on to, but came down to make
himself a sacrifice for us. So the
Messiah Christ willingly humbled himself
to take on humanity and then to die to
pay the penalty of sin to satisfy his
own justice against sin. He emptied
himself voluntarily of his divine
privileges. John
20:28 Thomas came to Jesus and said when
he saw the nails in his hand the risen
Christ he said my Lord and my God and
Jesus did not correct him. The Holy
Spirit is also divine. John 14:16. This
is the I I want to uh encourage you to
look for a script I mean a sermon on
3ABN that's called his presence in the
cube hour long sermon that gives you all
the scripture references but John 14:16
Jesus said I'll pray the father he will
give you another helper in the Greek
that's alos paracletos that means
another one not just similar in nature
but one who is exactly like me that he
may abide with you forever. So this is a
clear indication that the Holy Spirit's
not just a a force but a divine person.
The Holy Spirit in Acts many times in
Acts an example Acts
13:2 he speaks, he comforts, he teaches,
he guides, he can fix, he functions.
Look at John
14:26, John 16:13.
He has
emotions. He's like a person. He can be
grieved. Acts 5 3-4 Paul said or Peter
said that Ananas when he lied it was not
just to men but to God when he lied to
the Holy Spirit. So from creation to the
baptism to the great commission we see
all three in existence. Amen. Very good.
Thank you for sharing that. A lot of
people have questions about that. All
right, but we've got those answers right
in the word of God. All right, Pastor
Mooney, here's your first
question. How can how can one know if
someone is a prophet? A close friend of
mine, a devoted follower of Christ, has
been experiencing small glimpses of the
future in her dreams, and they have come
to pass. She is unsure of what is
happening and where they are from and
has been seeking God's guidance as they
have been occurring for some years now.
Could you kindly share insight into the
signs of a prophet and whether this
could be a valid experience? That's from
Jenny who emailed that to us. All right.
Well, Jenny, thank you so much for that
question. We've got several examples in
of prophets in the Bible. Let me start
with a definition of prophecy. It's
found in 1 Corinthians chapter 14 where
Paul he's been scolding the Corinthians
for misusing the gift of tongues. And in
verse three he says he that prophesieth
speaketh unto men to edification and
exhortation and comfort. So to edify
means to build up or strengthen. We say
an edifice or stronghold. We mean to
exhort means to implore, to intreat, to
besiege, to invoke or to plead. So
someone that's doing all these or in
comfort means to console or encourage.
So when someone is doing these things,
they're building up or encouraging,
strengthening or imploring or pleading
with someone to follow Jesus or take the
narrow way. They're actually prophesying
according to the Bible definition. In
verse five, Paul says he wishes that
everyone would prophesy. It sounds like
prophecy involves more than just seeing
into the future. So we have an example
of young Samuel when he when he uh God
spoke to him in 1st Samuel chapter 3 in
verse one it says and the child Samuel
ministered unto the Lord before Eli and
the word of the Lord was precious or
scarce in those days there was no open
vision. And so it sounds like Samuel's
life was in harmony with God's will. It
says he was ministering to the Lord and
serving the high priest which was Eli.
So you might recall the story of God
speaking audibly to this child Samuel
and he thinking it was Eli. In verse 7
it says,"Now Samuel did not know the
Lord, neither was the word of the Lord
yet revealed unto him." So this was a
new experience for him like your close
friend uh Jenny. God revealed to Samuel
the judgments he was going to bring upon
Israel, specifically to the house of Eli
for not correcting his sons who were
corrupting the
priesthood. And in verse 15, it says
that Samuel was scared to tell Eli the
vision. But Eli threatened Samuel. And
so then he told Eli what God had
revealed to him. So in verse 19, it says
that Samuel grew and the Lord was with
him and did let none of his words fall
to the ground. Meaning from then on,
whatever the Lord revealed to him, he
fulfilled his duty. Even if he was
scared, he still shared with whatever
the Lord wanted him to do. So as far as
knowing whether someone is called to be
a prophet, we see in verse 20 it says,
"And all Israel from Dan even to Beersa
knew that Samuel was established to be a
prophet of the Lord." So it was that
people around him that recognized that
he was called to be a prophet. You know,
I would encourage your friend to listen
to what the Lord is sharing with her and
carrying out his will and what the Holy
Spirit's prompting her to do, being
faithful to her duty and then trusting
the Lord and God will reveal to others.
That seems to be the way the Bible
brings out whether someone is a prophet
or not. We should all be encouraging,
edifying, and exhorting each other to
follow Jesus. 1 John 4:1 says, "Beloved,
believe not every spirit, but try the
spirits whether they are of God, because
many false prophets are gone out into
the world." Matthew 7:20 says,
"Wherefore, by their fruits you shall
know them." So, this is something solemn
to think about when you're edifying,
exhorting, or encouraging someone to do
something or to not do something. You're
actually
prophesying. And could we could say that
a prophet is a spokesperson for someone.
Ultimately, there are only two spirits,
good or evil, God or Satan. God's spirit
is being poured out upon all flesh.
According to Joel 2:28 says, "Some will
dream dreams and others will see
visions." So again, thank you for that
question and encourage your friend there
to be faithful to what she's hearing the
Holy Spirit speaking to her and then
sharing with others, not letting
anything fall to the ground. Thank you
for sharing. Amen. Thank you very much,
sir. All right, Pastor James, I've got
your first question here. Before his
death on the stake, the religious
leaders asked Yeshua for a sign. He
replied that the only sign would be the
sign of Jonah, who was three days and
three nights in the belly of the fish.
So would the Son of Man be in the
grave. Show me three days and three
nights from Friday night to Sunday
morning. That's from Norm in Michigan
who texted that to us. Well, thank you,
Norm in Michigan. And let's begin with
what Jesus says in Matthew
12:40. For as Jonah was three days and
three nights in the whale's belly, so
shall the Son of Man be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth.
Remember that phrase, the heart of the
earth. Now, sometimes we look for three
24-hour days and three 24-hour nights.
However, the Bible uses inclusive
reckoning, which means that part of a
day is counted for a day. Now, we know
this because of verses like Matthew
16:21. Let me read that verse. From that
time forth, Jesus began to show unto his
disciples how that he must go to
Jerusalem, suffer many things of the
elders and the chief priests and
scribes, and be killed, and be raised
again the third day. And we there's a
lot of verses on this. Matthew 17:23,
Matthew 20:19, Mark 9:31, Acts
10:38-4. on the third day means that the
third day would not be fully spent by
the time Christ was resurrected. Yet, it
is still counted as the third day. This
is inclusive reckoning. That is part of
a day is counted as the day even though
it is not a full 24 hours. We can talk a
little bit more about that later or I'll
give you some references if we run out
of time. Now, apart from inclusive
reckoning, your question is about the
actual days and nights. So, let's take a
closer look at how that works. In the
Bible, night comes before day, as in the
evening and the morning were the first
day. Genesis 15:8, 131, 19,23, and 31
all follow that pattern. So the first
night of the three nights is Thursday
when Jesus was arrested. According to
John 18:3, Judas, then having received a
band of men and officers from the chief
priests and Pharisees, comethther with
lanterns and torches and weapons. So
that's indicates that it's night time.
It's dark. So this is night one. Now
biblically it's Friday night because of
course biblically the night comes before
the day. So it's dark on Friday night.
Then there's Friday when Jesus was tried
and crucified and died. So that is day
one. That is Friday night being Thursday
night. But Friday night in the Bible
that is the day the day evening and the
morning were the first day. Then we have
Friday night which is the second night
or Sabbath day night. Remember the day
become a night becomes for the day and
this is followed by the second day which
is the Sabbath. So now we have two
nights and two days. Then the Sabbath
day is followed by Sabbath night which
biblically speaking is Sunday night and
then we have so that's our third night
and then we have Saturday night followed
by Sunday morning which gives us the
third day. So that's how we get three
days and three nights. Now again the
Bible is using inclusive reckoning for
these days and nights. That means
they're not reckoned by a full 24-hour
period. And obviously they're not. So we
have three days, Friday, Sabbath, and
Sunday. And we have three nights,
Friday, night, Sabbath night, Sunday
night, which comes before the days. So
understanding of course that that each
night comes first. So now if you want a
more thorough study on this or a longer
study on this, you can email me at
james.rafy3abn.org. But let me just give
you a few more verses that will help
with this. Um first of all for the third
day reckoning we're going to look at
Luke 21 and just read the whole chapter
and you'll notice that today is the
third day is what the disciples on the
road to Emmas are talking about. Jesus
was resurrected on the third day. So
again that's inclusive reckoning. Uh we
see that in 1 kings 12:es 5 and 12. We
also see it in 2 Chronicles 10:es 5 and
12. The heart of the earth now this is
important. The heart of the earth is not
talking about the fact that Jesus would
be dead for three nights. The heart of
the earth is referring to Jesus being
betrayed by Jesus. When you look at uh
Matthew 12:40, Matthew 17:22, and
Matthew 17:23, you're going to find that
Jesus talked about three days and three
nights in the context of being betrayed
into the hands of men. That would be the
first night of the three nights. And of
course that took place when Jesus Christ
was taken by the mob in the garden on
Thursday night or we should say uh the
biblically Friday night. That is the the
night of the Friday. So hopefully that's
helpful. Matthew 240 John Matthew 17:22
and Matthew 17:23 really explain the
heart of the earth. Again, I can give
you a more detailed study on that if
you'd like to send me an email. God
bless. Amen. Thank you very much, sir.
That was a very good answer. All right,
Sister Shelley. I've got your second
question here.
What does it mean to put God first? When
I wake up, I usually say a short prayer,
eat breakfast, and then do my morning
devotion. Does this mean I am not
putting God first? Or is it about
something deeper than the order of
actions in the morning? That's from
Annabelle from the UK who emailed that
to us. Annabelle, I love your question.
I love your heart. Matthew 6:33 Jesus
said, "Seek first the kingdom of God and
his righteousness and all these things
will be added to you." What he's saying
is allow God's rule, God's righteousness
to shape your every decision, your
desire, and your direction in life.
He is Jesus is providing us with a
divine
priority to live by in a world where
everything else can distract us from
living for God. It you know we get so
much it's easy to let family or your
friends or your career or even ministry
come and take that place before you your
relationship with God. But Jesus is
telling us to reorder our lives, making
God our top priority, seeking him first.
It is more than just saying grace before
your meals. Revelation 3:20 says Jesus
stands at the door and knocks. And he
says, "If you'll answer the door and let
me in, I'll come in and dine with you."
He wants a place at the table. He wants
to be with you every moment of every
day. And so basically this shifts us
from saying hm what do I want to do
today to going to the Lord and say Lord
what do you desire for me to do today?
Annabelle there's three ways we can tell
we are seeking God first. One our
priorities begin to align with heaven's
values. We're yielding to God's
instruction, his direction. We're
believing his wisdom is greater than
ours because he knows he and from the
beginning his timing is always perfect.
In Proverbs 3:5 and 6, we're learning to
trust in the Lord with all of our heart.
Lean not on our own understanding. And
in all our ways, God directs us. The
second thing, after our priorities,
aligning with heaven, our peace is no
longer tied to our
circumstances. Matthew 6:34, right
before Right after Jesus said, "Seek
first." What does he say? Do not worry
about tomorrow. You know, every day has
got enough worries of its own. So fear
loses its grip when God is first in our
life. We know we're living under the
care of our heavenly father. And our
desires, number three, our desires begin
to change.
Psalm 37:4. Some people misuse this
scripture, but it says, "Delight
yourself in the Lord. He shall give you
the desires of your heart." It's not a
promise that God is going to fulfill
your every wish. What it is is
transformation. The closer we live to
God, the more we want what he wants. He
transforms. He makes his desires our
desires. That's seeking first. Amen.
Amen. Thank you very much, sister. All
right, Pastor Moroning, here's your
second
question. I receive social security and
a small pension. I tithe 10% and give
offerings. Are there other tithes we are
supposed to give besides 10%. I'm
confused about first fruits. That's from
Sarah in Kentucky who texted that to us.
Thank you, Sarah. Well, first of all, I
want to affirm you for your faithfulness
in paying your tithe or returning your
tithes and offerings. You know, we have
God's promise here in Malachi chapter
3:10. Bring ye all the tithes into the
storehouse that there may be meat in
mine house and prove me now herewith,
sayeth the Lord of hosts, if I will not
open you the windows of heaven, and pour
you out a blessing that there shall not
be room enough to receive it. So, I'm
sure you've experienced God's blessing
upon you over the years, and possibly
you have a miracle story of God
providing for you. In this verse, God is
challenging us to test him. You be
faithful in returning your tithe, and he
will show himself faithful to take care
of you. Amen. You asked about the first
fruit offerings. We find a direct
reference to this in Leviticus chapter
23, beginning with verse 9. And the Lord
spake unto Moses, saying, Speak unto the
children of Israel, and say unto them,
When ye come into the land, which I will
give unto you, and shall reap the
harvest thereof, you shall bring a
sheath of the first fruits of your
harvest unto the priest, and he shall
wave the sheath before the Lord to be
accepted for you. On the tomorrow after
the Sabbath the priest shall wave it and
ye shall offer that day when ye wave the
sheath and and he lamb without blemish
of the first year for a burnt offering
unto the Lord. And then the meat
offering thereof shall be two tenth
deals of fine flour mingled with oil and
offering made by fire unto the Lord for
a sweet savor. And the drink offering
thereof shall be of wine the fourth part
of an hen which is about a one and a
half gallons. The system of tithes and
offerings was actually intended to
impress the minds of men with a great
truth that God is the source of every
blessing to his creatures and that to
him man's gratitude is due for the good
gifts of his providence. The first of
every product of the land was
consecrated to God. The first of the
wool when the sheep were shorn of the
grain when the wheat was threshed or
barley the first of the oil and the wine
was set apart for God. So also were the
firstborn of all the animals and a
redemption price was paid for the
firstborn son. The first fruits were to
be presented before the Lord at the
sanctuary and where they were devoted to
the use of the priests. So as far as
bringing this idea of first fruits into
practical for us today, Sarah, maybe you
could think of doing what I've been
doing as far as you know when you get
your check or whatever, you make out
your tithes and offerings first. be that
the first thing and then you can look at
yourself say, "Wow, look at all this
money that the Lord has allowed me to do
whatever I want with for his glory."
Anyway, thank you for that question. I
hope that was a help to you. Amen. Thank
you, sir. Thank you. All right, Pastor
James, here's your second
question. How do we explain Revelation
chap 20 verse 10 to people? Especially
the part that says forever and ever.
That's from Tina who sent that to us via
chat on our website.
Well, thank you Tina for that question.
It's an important one. You know, the
Bible says that the devil that deceives
them is cast into the lake of fire and
brimstone where the beast and the false
prophet are and they shall be tormented
day and night forever and ever. And that
is a phrase that is used quite a number
of times in the Bible. And it makes
people think that the suffering of the
devil and his angels, in fact, the
suffering of all those who are lost is
going to be eternal. In other words,
it's going to continue on without stop
for all ages. But what does this
expression mean in the context of all
the Bible evidence? Now, the use of this
expression is found in other places in
the Bible and that can really help us to
find harmony with its use here. Let's
look at a few examples. In Exodus
chapter 21 and verse 6, a servant that
chose not to leave his master was then
to serve him, that is to serve his
master forever, quote unquote. Now, that
doesn't mean that this servant was going
to be serving him forever. Let's look at
the verse itself. It says, "Then his
master shall bring him unto the judges.
He shall also bring him to the door and
unto the doorpost, and his master shall
bore his ear through with an all, and he
shall serve him forever." And by the
way, this is a a beautiful illustration
of what Christ was pierced for us.
Became one with the human race for us
for all eternity. He's going to be be
the son of man. And he has chosen to
even serve us. We know when we get to
the heaven, we're going to sit down at
the marriage supper of the lamb and he's
going to serve us there. So an a shadow
there, a type of Christ in this. Now, of
course, that doesn't mean that this
servant was going to serve him for all
eternity. He was going to serve him as
long as he was alive. And it's the same
with the lost. They're going to suffer
as long as they're alive. But Malachi 4
tells us very clearly that they will
become ashes under our feet. So once the
servant died, he could no longer serve
his master. How about 1st Samuel 1 and
verse 22? Hannah purposed to present her
son to the Lord that he would abide
there forever. Again, this was
understood to mean as long as he Samuel
lives. And you can just compare 1st
Samuel 1:22 with 1st Samuel 1:28. It
says there, "But Hannah went up not, for
she said unto her husband, I will not go
up until the child be weaned, and then I
will bring him that they may appear
before the Lord, and thereby forever."
And then it goes on to say, I have also
lent him to the Lord as long as he
lives. Verse 28, he shall be lent to the
Lord, and he worshiped the Lord there.
So again, we find the term forever used
to explain something that is referring
to as long as someone lives. Uh Jonah is
another example. In Jonah chapter 2:6,
he says, "I went down to the bottoms of
the mountains. The earth of the her bars
was around me forever and uh yet you
have brought me up and my life from
corruption, oh Lord my God." So Jonah
was not literally in the belly of the
whale for an indefinite forever. He was
there for a short space of time, uh
three days, three nights, uh inclusive
reckoning, which we've already talked
about. In fact, any negative experience
we have, especially when we're
uncomfortable, can seem like an
eternity. In fact, we use that term
analogy today. You know, this is taking
forever or where were you? I've been
waiting forever. Or when are we going to
get there? We've been driving forever.
All right. So, it's just it's an idiom.
It's it's an expression that we use
about something that is possibly
uncomfortable or seems to be taking a
very long time. I hope this is helpful
answering your question, Tina. Amen.
Amen. Thank you very much, sir. All
right, Sister Shelley, I've got your
third question, but let me remind our
viewers at home how you can participate
with this program. One of three ways.
You can send us an email
to
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. Or you can send us a
text message to
618-2283975. That's
618-228-3975. And then for those of you
who are on Instagram, send us your
questions in that way as well at 3ABN
official. At 3ABN official. All right,
Shelley, here's your third question. Is
there power in prayer or the blood of
Jesus? That's from Sterling who emailed
that to us. Sterling, there's power in
both. I love this question. There's
wonder working power in the blood of
Jesus. Our creator God became the son of
man. He died to pay our penalty, to
satisfy his own justice against sin, to
make us righteous by faith. And his
blood is not merely symbolic. It's the
very lifeline to our redemption.
Ephesians 1 says 17 says we have
redemption through his blood, the
forgiveness of sins. His blood breaks
the chains. I don't care what's going on
in your life. His blood silences the
accuser, Satan. He gives us bold access
by the blood of Jesus to the throne of
grace as Hebrews
4:16 says. You know, Satan trembles at
the mention of the blood of Christ
because it sealed his defeat and it
sealed our victory. Revelation 12:11
says they overcome by the blood of the
lamb and by the word of their testimony.
But guess what? The story doesn't stop
at Calvary. Jesus rose. He resurrected.
He now intercedes as our high priest in
the heavens. Hebrews 7:25 says he is
able to save to the uttermost those who
come to God through him since he always
lives to make intercession for them. So
that's why there's unstoppable power not
just in the blood of Christ but in
prayer there is unstoppable power. It's
when it's anchored when you're in
covenant relationship you're in Christ.
You're praying in Christ. When we pray
in the name of Jesus, we're not praying
to a distant God. We're praying to the
one who stooped so low as to take on our
flesh and die for us. And now he he
bends down his ear to us to listen to
this prayer. And when we pray, we come
before him. We are cleansed. We're
covered. And we are claimed as his
child. James 5:16 says, "The effective
fervent prayer of a righteous man avails
much." Prayer is not how long you pray.
Prayer is who you're praying to. And
it's the righteousness of Christ that
makes our our prayers powerful. The same
Jesus who poured out his blood for you
bends low to hear your cry. No sin too
deep, no bondage that is too strong.
There's no need too great. Jesus paid it
all and he invites you to come boldly
before his throne. Lift up your voice.
Call on him. Plead the blood. Heaven
moves when a bloodbought child of God
dares to believe. Amen.
Two-hander.
Wow. Power in prayer. Power in the blood
of Christ. Amen. Thank you, sister. All
right, Pastor Moroni. Here's your third
question. What does Matthew 15:11 mean?
That's from Ruth who emailed that to us.
Well, thank you, Ruth, for that
question. And we need to begin with
verse one of this chapter to get the
context of what Jesus means here and
it's in Matthew chapter 15
um 1-9. Then came to Jesus scribes and
Pharisees saying, "Why do thy disciples
transgress to the tradition of the
elders? for they wash not their hands
when they eat. But he answered and said
unto them, Why do ye also transgress the
commandment of God for your tradition?
For God commanded, saying, Honor thy
father and mother, and he that cursseeth
father or mother, let him die the death.
But ye say, whosoever shall say to his
father or mother, it's a gift. By
whatsoever thou mightest be profited by
me. And verse six says, "And honorth not
his father and his mother, he shall be
free. Thus have ye made the commandment
of God of none effect by your tradition.
Ye hypocrites, well did Isaiah prophesy
of you, saying, this people draweth nigh
unto me with their mouth, and honorth me
with their lips, but their heart is far
from me." But in vain do they worship
me, teaching for doctrines the
commandments of men. Then in verse 10 it
says, "And he called a multitude, and he
said unto them, hear and understand,
it's not that which goeth into the mouth
that defileth a man, but that which
cometh out of the mouth that defileth a
man, but those things which proceed out
of the mouth come forth from the heart,
and they defile the man. For out of the
heart proceed evil thoughts, murders,
adulteries, fornications, thefts, and
false witness, blasphemies. These are
the things which defile a man. But to
eat with unwashed hands defileth not a
man. And so here's the rest of the
story. Jesus's disciples were putting
things into their mouth without washing
their hands, which this was a tradition
that the Pharisees had imposed that was
an extension of the Mosaic laws
requirement for a priest to wash their
hands before entering the tabernacle. So
Jesus was pointing out their hypocrisy
of being overly strict in one area to
make it appear that they were really
extra holy people. Yet, they were going
directly against God's holy ten
commandments uh law that says that we're
to honor our parents, which included
taking care of them in their declining
years by providing for them. They made
up a law that said that you didn't have
to do that if you would promise that you
would give a gift to the temple. And and
Mark does this talking about the same
situation here. the this word for
declaring it a gift was called corban
and that's in Mark 7:11 which meant you
were dedicating a certain portion of
your wealth to God that was exempting
you from providing for your aging
parents. So what's on the inside of us
is it comes out of our mouths that
reveals more to more about our walk with
Jesus or our holiness rather than our
external rituals that we do. Thank you
for the question. Amen. Thank you sir.
Thank
you. All right, Pastor James, here's
your third
question. What is God's will? That's
from Phillip in Canada who texted that
to us.
Well, Philip, that is a huge question
that you brought uh to the table today.
You know, God's will in general, let's
just generalize here. Uh God's will in
general is that we would experience the
new covenant promise that's outlined in
Hebrews chapters 8 uh chapter 8 and
chapter 10 but 8:es 10-12 it says for
this is the covenant that I will make
with the house of Israel after those
days sayeth the Lord I will put my law
into their minds write them in their
hearts I will be to them a god they
shall be to me a people they shall not
teach every man his neighbor and every
man his brother saying know the Lord for
all shall know me from the least to the
greatest for I will be merciful in their
to unto their unrighteousness and their
sins and their iniquities I will
remember no more. You know, in fact, uh
another word for covenant is actually a
will, right, Shel? A will or a
testament. So, God's will or covenant
for us uh ever has been this new
covenant experience that's laid out in
these verses. Uh God's power that we
would rely on God's power. I will put my
law in their hearts. God's law to live
God's law of love in our hearts. um to
be God's people, right? And to have
God's spirit, to be anointed of the
spirit of God, so we don't need others
to teach us that we can be led of the
Holy Spirit. And then God's forgiveness,
the experience of God's forgiveness.
Now, this is confirmed, this general
will of God is confirmed in many other
places like for example Psalm 40:8 says,
"I delight to do thy will, oh my God,
yay, thy law is within my heart." or 1
Thessalonians 4:3 which says for this is
the will of God even your sanctification
that you should abstain from fornication
or 1 Thessalonians 5 and:1 18 in
everything give thanks for this is the
will of God in Christ Jesus concerning
you or what about first Peter 4:2 that
we should no longer live the rest of his
life in in or time in the flesh to the
lust of men but to the will of God Now,
we're generalizing here, but if we want
to get a little bit more specific
though, we're going to generalize again,
we could go to 1 John chapter 2 15 to1
17. Notice what it says here. All that
is in the world, the lust of the flesh,
the lust of the eyes, the pride of life
is not of the father, but is of the
world, and the world passes away, and
the lust thereof, but he that does the
will of God abides forever. So, doing
the will of God is actually doing things
that are completely opposite of the
world, of the lust of the flesh, the
lust of the eyes, and the pride of life.
In other words, it's living for God
rather than living for the world. It's
surrendering our hearts to God and
following his will, his revealed will.
Now, what is that specific will? For
example, does God want me to get married
or does God want me to have this certain
job or does God want me to go in this
certain direction, live in this certain
location? If you'd like, you can uh
email me at
james.raferty3abn.com and I can or.org
org and I can send you uh an outline of
how we can know God's will for our
lives. And of course, one of the ways
Shelley already talked about or we've
already talked about a little bit is is
to pray and to ask for God's power to be
revealed in our lives so that we can
know that he is leading us. Uh so
hopeful this is helpful for you at least
in a general sense to understand the
answer to your question about knowing
God's will. Amen. Amen. Thank you,
pastor. All right, Sister Shelley,
here's your last question. Is human free
will limited or unlimited based on
examples in the Bible like David's
choices and Pharaoh's heart being
hardened? What does this mean for our
understanding of God's sovereignty and
love for him? That's from Mark who
texted that to us. Mark, what a
wonderful question. Let me explain God's
sovereignty first. This means that
sovereignty that God reigns as the
supreme ruler. He orchestrates the grand
narrative of everything that happens in
the cosmos. Even the intricate details
of our lives. He's our creator, our
sustainer, our redeemer, and his
ultimate purpose is behind all
existence. He operates by a government
of love. So this sovereign God bestowed
upon humanity a sacred gift of free
will. And you might free will just means
we've got the right to determine our own
actions. And you might say, why would
God give humans free will where they
could mess up for the sake of love? He
could do nothing less. Love doesn't
control. Love doesn't coersse. If God
hadn't given us free will, we'd have
been nothing more than robots that had a
programmed intelligence to actually
accomplish routine tasks. So God created
us for a
heartto-heart relationship with him. And
to share true joy and love with him, we
have to be able to choose him. To God,
it was worth the risk. Deuteronomy 30 19
and 20 God says that he sets life and
death before us. Choose life. Luke 9:23
Jesus says if anyone desires to come
after me, let him pick up his cross and
follow me. Desire is this implies
freedom. You're wanting something. So
there's this tension between divine
sovereignty and human freedom. But it
reveals a God whose love does not
coersse. He calls. He warns. He pleads.
But he never forces us. What he does. He
doesn't control us. But he brings us
along. He draws us, woos us with cords
of love. And one thing though he does is
our choices bring
responsibilities. There consequences to
our choices. And we'll look at First
Samuel 17. Well, I'll just mention this.
In 1st Samuel 17, King David chose to
follow God. Now, in 2 Samuel 11, he also
chose to sin with Ba Sheeba. God didn't
force either action. But it's
interesting because 2 Samuel 12, he held
David accountable and called him to
repentance. So now let's look at
Pharaoh's story because this is really
shows divine sovereignty and human
stubbornness. Exodus in nine times it
mentions that Pharaoh hardened his own
heart. Then nine times it mentions that
God hardened his heart. This doesn't
contradict free will. It actually is
explaining or reflecting a biblical
principle when people continually resist
God. Well, you can get to that point of
no return. He confirms them in their
chosen path. Psalm 81:11 and 12, God
says, "My people who would not heed my
voice, so I gave them over to their own
stubborn heart to walk in their own
counselss." Romans 20 1:24, Paul
describes a similar thing. He says, "God
gave them up to their chosen path when
they persistently rejected him." So
God's
judgment is sometimes just to let people
have what they stubbornly are choosing.
The bottom line, I guess, how I would
say it, if it makes sense, free will is
limited in its power, but it's not
limited in purpose. It gives us the
ability to love
God freely. That's the highest
expression of worship. And this balance
reveals something profound about God.
His sovereignty doesn't cancel human
freedom. He didn't cause Pharaoh to to
sin. But I love Romans 8:28 and 29 that
God works all things together for good
for those who love him and are called
according to his purpose. For those he
forneew, he predestined to be conformed
to the image of Jesus. So God works
through our free will. And sometimes
I've made bad choices, but God has
worked me through to help create the
image of Christ in me. Amen. Amen. Thank
you, sister. Thank you. All right,
Pastor Moroni, here's your last
question. Can you explain Deuteronomy
12:es 12- 25? That's from Sharon in
Jamaica who emailed that to us. Thank
you, Sharon, for that question.
Let's go to the beginning just to get
the context. Beginning of chapter 12
there in Deuteronomy. It says in verse
two, "Ye shall utterly destroy all the
places where in the nations which ye
shall possess, serve their gods upon the
high mountains and upon the hills and
under every green tree. And ye shall
overthrow their altars and break their
pillars and burn their groves with fire.
And ye shall hue down the graven images
of their gods and destroy the names of
them out of their place."
So basically they were worshiping these
other idols all over the place there in
the land that God was giving to the
Israelites. In verse 5 it says, "But
unto the place which the Lord your God
shall choose out of your tribes to put
his name there, even unto his habitation
shall ye seek, and thither thou shalt
come." And then down to verse 8, it
says, "Ye shall not do after all the
things that we do here this day. Every
man whatsoever is right in his own
eyes." They were just doing their own
thing wherever they wanted groves
everywhere they were doing their own
orgies or whatever their kind of
worships were. Verse 11, then there
shall be a place which the Lord your God
shall choose to cause his name to dwell
there. Thither shall ye bring all that I
command you, your burnt offerings, and
your sacrifices, your tithes, and your
heave offerings of your hand, and all
your choice vows, which ye shall vow
unto the Lord. So he wanted them to get
to a certain spot. This is pre getting
into the promised land. So Moses was
speaking for God what they were to do.
So in coming to where you were talking
about here in verse 12 through 15 says
he wanted them to come. It said
whatsoever thy soul lustth after
according to the blessing of the Lord
thy God which he hath given thee. The
unclean and the clean may eat thereof as
of the robuk and as of the heart. These
are actually two clean animals according
to Deuteronomy 14:5.
They parted the hoof and chewed the cud
where it says thy soul lustth after.
Today we would maybe more say uh eating
to your heart's desire rather than
lusting after because it has a different
connotation. So notice it says here
according to the blessing of the Lord
thy God which he hath given thee. The
laws of clean and unclean animals
they're found in Leviticus 11 and
Deuteronomy 14. And it's in 14 or 11:47
says to make a difference between the
unclean and the clean, between the beast
that may be eaten and that may not be
eaten. So Sharon, you may be wondering
what it meant or means when it says in
verse 15, the unclean and the clean may
eat thereof. Well, this is actually
speaking of the person that's doing the
eating of these clean animals. Okay, to
their heart's desire. They had laws
regarding a person being ceremonially
clean or unclean. And these are found in
Leviticus chapter 12-15. And they have
to do with a person coming into contact
with unclean things like dead bodies,
skin diseases, and bodily discharges. If
they did come into the contact with
something unclean, it was made them
ceremony unclean for a specified amount
of time and they were to do certain
things to make them clean again. Thank
you again for the question. Amen. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you, sir. Good
answer. All right, Pastor James, here's
your last question.
Can you please explain Revelation
11:8? While this section of scripture is
dealing with the French 3 and a half
year period of idolatry, Egypt, and
immorality, Sodom, between 1793 and
1798. I'm struggling with the last line
of verse 8, where our Lord was
crucified. Please help me understand
this. That's from Daniel in Kenya who
sent that to us via chat on our website.
Thank you for that question, Daniel and
Kenya. You know, let's just look at the
verse in question. It's Revelation 11:8.
And their dead body shall lie in the
street of that great city which is
spiritually called Sodom and Egypt where
also our Lord was crucified. Now we see
this prophetic declaration where our
Lord was crucified as being fulfilled in
France in two ways. Now the first way
the disciples of Christ uh were the
first way is the way the disciples of
Christ were treated because the Bible
says in Matthew 25:40 and the king shall
answer say unto them verily I say unto
you in as much as you have done it to
the least of these my brethren you have
done it unto me. In other words Christ
is crucified in the person of his
disciples. And in France during the
French Revolution you have that taking
place. So where our Lord is crucified
would refer to the persecution that
Christ visited upon the confessors of
the gospel. Um in doing that she had
crucified Christ in the person of his
disciples. Um Jesus Christ was declared
to be an impostor and uh the French
infidels said crush the wrench crush the
wrench meaning Christ and this
heavenaring blasphemy and abomination of
wickedness went hand in hand. So
basically the the basis of men the most
abandoned monsters of cruelty and vice
uh were uh exalting themselves against
the followers of Christ against the
gospel against the truth and Christ and
his character of truth of purity of
unselfish love was basically being
crucified. But secondly we also see uh
this Christ being crucified phrase being
uh fulfilled in the way the Bible was
treated. You know, the Bible is
basically a revelation of God himself.
In fact, in John chapter 1 and verse
one, we're told in the beginning was the
word, and the word was with God, and the
word was God. And in Revelation 19:13,
when it talks about Christ returning uh
on horses uh with an army of horsemen,
it says the angels, it says that he is a
vesture dipped in blood, and his name is
called the Word of God. So when the
beast ascends out of the bottomless pit
he makes war against the two witnesses
which represents the old and new
testament and he in doing this the word
of god the bible was war upon as it
never the world had never witnessed. The
word of god was prohibited by the
national assembly. Bibles were collected
they were publicly burned. Uh every um
every law of god was trampled underfoot.
The institutions of the bible were
abolished. The weekly rest day was set
aside. uh baptism and communion were
prohibited which are two teachings of
the word of God and announcement
announcements were posted um everywhere
uh over the burial places of of the dead
saying that they were in eternal sleep
there wouldn't be any resurrection so
first of all where our lord was
crucified refers to the way that god's
followers his disciples were treated
because when you do it to one of the
least of these my brethren you do it to
me and secondly it refers to the way the
bible itself was treated in the French
revolution a lot symbolism there. I hope
those those uh two applications help
with your answer. Amen. Amen. Thank you
very much. Wow. Time has gone by pretty
fast, hasn't it? Well, we're going to be
taking a short break here in just a
moment, but I want to remind you or let
you know you can get a lot of these
answers to your Bible questions on our
website,
3ABNBibleansers.com. Have you heard that
website before? You should check it out.
You can get questions answered on topics
on the Antichrist, questions on the
topic of baptism, on the topic of
divorce, heaven, and judgment. A lot of
different Bible questions. You can find
those answers there. So, check out
3ABNBibleansers.com. Well, we're going
to take a short break to let you know,
remind you how you can participate with
3ABNTday Bible Q&A. So, don't go away.
We'll be right
back. If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible
Q&A, then tell your friends. Each
Monday, we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. You may also text your
questions to
618-228-3975. That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word. Thanks for coming back. Let's get
some final thoughts from our panelists.
Pastor James, let's start with you.
Yeah, I just wanted to touch a little
bit more on the heart of the earth and
that three days and three nights. You
know, we talked about the heart of the
earth uh representing not the time that
Christ was in the grave, but beginning
with the time that he was betrayed into
the hands of uh the mob, but it actually
starts before then. It starts uh when
Jesus Christ is in a sense forsaken of
God. He's in Gethsemane and he's already
experiencing the separation struggle,
sweating great drops of blood, feeling
the guilt and the weight of the sins of
the world. So that's when it all begins
and of course that begins on Friday
night. Then you have Saturday night,
Sunday night, or in our day, in our
reckoning, Thursday night, Friday night,
Saturday night. Amen. Amen. Pastor
Mooney. Well, on that uh prophecy one,
the John the Revelator actually sees the
last church. They're prophesying because
in uh Revelation 12:1 17, it says that
they have the testimony of Jesus and
19:10 says it's the spirit of prophecy.
So the last group of people on this
earth, they'll be having that spirit of
edifying each other, exhorting each
other, and comforting each other. Amen.
Sister Shelley, I'm just thinking about
seeking first the God, the kingdom of
heaven. You know, if you think about
this, the it's not easy to seek first.
But the more we practice his presence,
the easier it becomes. So pick up your
Bible before you pick up your phone in
the morning. Amen. Talk to God in prayer
before you talk with the world. Amen.
And and just lay your plans at the altar
and let him tell you what he wants from
you. Amen. Amen. I'll leave you with
this fun scripture song from 1 Peter
chapter 3:15. But sanctify the Lord God
in your hearts and always be ready to
give a defense to everyone who ask you a
reason for the hope that is in you with
meekness and fear. Thanks. God bless.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.